now then therefore a fascinating story
normally reserved for things like
Hollywood films the Pentagon has
Declassified three videos let's have a
look at them which appeared as you can
see for yourself unidentified objects
flying through the sky in many cases
identified by US Air Force pilots that
the black and white videos were recorded
by those pilots one in November 2004 -
back in January 2015 so not too long ago
the footage had been shared online
unofficially it had been leaked and has
been well known to UFO enthusiasts but
the Pentagon said it had chosen to
release the videos officially now well
let's talk more about that and other
conspiracy theories with Cass Sunstein a
professor at Harvard who was the
administrator of the Office of
Information and regulatory affairs under
the Obama administration and has written
a book called conspiracy theories and
other dangerous ideas professor Sunstein
good to talk to you let's talk first of
all about we've all seen them now I know
they've been around for a bit cuz they
leaked - what do you make of those
videos
well society and life is full of
randomness and things that are hard to
explain and the chance that it's space
aliens or Martians or creatures from
Venus who just happen to be arriving at
a time when there's a pandemic I think I
take my chances on it's nothing that has
a worldly explanation well maybe they
come to save us but the fact is is that
the fact that they'd leaked and hadn't
been released now that has already led
to many many conspiracy theories of
course about a cover-up yes and isn't it
amazing that during a pandemic a lot of
sporting events have been canceled at
just the time when the nation's who have
been canceling the events had teams that
were likely to lose doesn't that make
you suspicious similarly I think the
fact that it's being released now
probably attests to nothing and if it
has to something it's probably
reasonably benign or much smaller than
the more exciting theory suggests but I
was thinking the fact that they hadn't
been released before yet those who like
to believe in UFOs and aliens and all
kinds of things some believe that the
authorities knew something and weren't
letting the public know about it well
here's what's I think interesting about
that way of thinking which we all are
prone to you know is that anytime that
there's a release of something that you
know seems like a puzzle maybe a
ufo-related puzzle anytime that happens
will be a time when it's fair to say why
now it might be a time when things are
fairly quiet so why now it might be time
when people are focused on climate
change so why now it might be at the
time of brexit it might be after brexit
has receded so the why now question
always can be passed in a way that has a
tone of voice that suggests very
suspicious yeah but when it comes to
UFOs they date back certainly into the
the 20th century into the middle of the
20th century I'm thinking of course
about the the Roswell incidents and that
still persists that they're long lasting
yes and the Roswell television show
which is serendipitously available at a
time of lockdown is actually fun really
fun but the likelihood is and I am
embarrassed to say I've actually
investigated the Roswell incident the
likelihood and I'm phrasing this very
gently is that it didn't involve anyone
and I use the word anyone to include
space aliens as well as people the
likelihood that it involved anyone from
outer space is vanishingly low and also
then of course we've got set Apollo 11
itself never went there it's all it's
all shot in the desert somewhere and the
lights all wrong and the flags in the
wrong place etc etc yes and what's
interesting about the spread of
conspiracy theories I think is that
there's a combination of individual
individuals are predisposed to believe
them so much so that they are likely to
believe mutually contradictory
conspiracy series theories such as Elvis
Presley was killed maybe by the Central
Intelligence Agency and also Elvis
Presley is still alive and actually
singing quietly in some remote area
people are likely to believe both of
those so there's a predisposition on
them on the part of some and also if
something is hitting someone's
individual life or their community or
the planet or their country then there's
a search for an explanation that can
give order to what would otherwise be a
kind of disorderly fear or anger and
that's I think one reason why we're
seeing so many conspiracy theories these
days including the ones involving UFOs
yeah and including the ones involving
corona virus that they're just
multiplying yes and there these are
really understandable because the idea
that something like this would happen so
suddenly and have such a massive effect
that really is in the nature of science
fiction or surreal and the human mind is
drawn to a pattern or an explanation and
if you would that's also a pattern then
there's a kind of calming that happens
you know sorry to cut you off must end
it there professor Sunstein thank you
very much indeed